for the run-up to the coronation to be
overshadowed by these Headlines by Harry
and Megan in this Royal rival court is
problematic so really a Reconciliation
is going to be in the best interests of
the firm can that actually happen answer
is not likely Royal Insider tells E.T
Prince William has no interest in
speaking to his brother Harry before
their father King Charles's coronation I
think most people are optimistic that
this relationship will heal over time I
just don't believe that the coronation
is going to be the place for that to
happen arasura says the Prince of Wales
is still upset about Harry's book spare
they are verbal attacks on members of
the royal family and not just any member
of the royal family his father his
brother his mother-in-law his
sister-in-law no one is really spared in
spare they've shown absolutely no
willingness to reconcile I would like to
get my father back I would like to have
my brother back and though Harry has
expressed an interest in reconciling The
Source says the relationship is still
fractured and it's unclear when they
will be able to mend fences William
feels it was a betrayal it's just too
big of an event it's too public there's
going to be too many people and too much
going on but hopefully it can be the
start of some real long-term healing
earlier this month Buckingham Palace
revealed Harry is attending the
coronation ceremony on May 6th without
his wife Meghan Markle nor their two
kids Archie and lillibet that's some
relief that he's actually going to his
father's coronation that hadn't been in
question certainly for the past few
weeks I'm surprised that Harry is going
alone not so much when you realize that
it's his son Archie's birthday the very
same day so Megan is in fact going to be
staying home in California to celebrate
that birthday which is perhaps quite
convenient given the tensions between
the two families right now speaking of
birthdays the palace is remembering
Queen Elizabeth on her years on April
21st she would have turned 97 to
celebrate William and his wife Kate
Middleton shared this sweet image of the
late Monarch with some of her grandkids
and great-grandkids there's their kiddos
Prince George princess Charlotte and
Prince Louis along with Prince Edward's
children and Princess Anne's
grandchildren noticeably missing Archie
and lillibet this image was snapped last
summer at Balmoral Castle by Kate
herself I mean Kate had 20 years to
really get to know the Monarch what a
privilege as a future Queen consort the
queen had a lot of time with her
great-grandchildren the queen would Host
this wonderful sleepover at Balmoral in
August and invite all of the
grandchildren and the great
grandchildren and
she looked forward to that weekend I
think probably more than any other
[Music]